bon qui a acheté ce cadeau de noël ouah
je vais acheter je veux pas t'entendre
d'accord cette vidéo c'est pour l'élite
c'est pour ceux qui les ont pas encore
acheté qui attendent le dernier moment
tout ce stress qu'on s'inflige chaque
année eh ben ça valait le coup parce
qu'aujourd'hui cette vidéo nous est
dédiée alors on a une petite sélection
de contenus qui tourne autour des
cadeaux de noël le but numéro un de
cette sélection nous inspirer je veux de
l'insp il a je faire des cadeaux qui
défonce chaque année j'offre les mêmes
trucs mon frère un objet de décoration
sauf que devinez quoi il est plus fort
que moi en déco et en art il me fut mme
mon cadeau a pas trop d'intérêt pour qui
je me prends à lui offrir un truc dans
lequel il est bien meilleur que moi ma
mère ma mère ma mort l'année dernière je
veux faire un aspirateur dyson
elle l'a mal pris je me confesse moment
j'ai un peu le même truc que mon père
mon père il déteste avoir à trouver des
cadeaux ça lui inflige un stress
monumental à tel point que pendant des
années et il avait dit à mon frère et
moi les gars on sauve pas de cadeau nous
on est au delà de ça on n'a pas besoin
mais au delà des fêtes on sait qu'on
s'aime
mais tu ne mets une douille papa en plus
de nous pénaliser pour le restant de nos
joueurs nous faire croire que c'est pas
grave de pauvres et de cadeaux en vrai
de vrai peu importe le prix d'un cadeau
on s'en fout ce pas ça qui compte ce qui
compte c'est la méta le truc qui va le
plus touché la personne que ça coûte un
euro ou 1000 euros bon c'est plus simple
que ça coûte un euro quand même bref il
nous reste quelques jours pour en
acheter normalement aujourd'hui cette
vidéo va vous aider ou au pire vous
stresse et bien évidemment il fallait
que ça tombe chez donc est ce qu'il a
fait ce gros malin voilà tous les
cadeaux
à 100 français
c'est minecraft qui voulait
non c'est pas pareil c'est un jeu vidéo
minecraft c'est pour les gamins
moi je vais vous dire ça me touche il a
préparé une petite blague avec son père
et son petit frère est un jeu d'acting
faites nous une pièce de théâtre là dans
votre famille vous avez ça dans le sang
si tu laisses ton grand frère prendre
une photo de toi sur laquelle tu es méga
moche on en fera un mug compte offrir à
noël les gars c'est génial les cadeaux
personnalisés comme ça un peu trop le
gag j'adore j'adore les cadeaux quand tu
les offres juste tu tapes une énorme
barre ça fait très plaisir franchement
regardez là on shoppe de lundi après six
jours avant noël on n'aura pas le temps
de faire des trucs perso pour l'année
prochaine ok en revanche sachez qu'il ya
pas longtemps j'ai pris la photo la plus
disgracieux ce qu'il soit de théo bonnec
a réalisé au times time en blanc
scandale et toutes mes grosses vidéos
depuis sept ans schéma trop pourquoi
mais il était fatigué de fouet à une
sieste et l'angle la lumière tout était
parfait ce jour là pour donner une photo
excécrable de lui vraiment c'est
incroyable je vais en faire un bug je
vais faire faire un mug personnalisé
avec la photo dont je vous parle là et
l'offrir à théo je vous jure je le fais
je vous mets ça à la fin de la vidéo il
va m'en vouloir parce qu elle ne fait
pas trop et que cette photo le pire
cadeau ever
assez des toilettes de chantier frérot
je suis vraiment pas sûr que ce soit le
pire cadeau wever je pense que c'est
tout l'inversé que quand tu bosses sur
un chantier et que les chiottes les plus
proches sont loin c'est le meilleur
cadeau qu'on puisse te faire honnêtement
toi qu'a fait ce poste sache que tu
seras moins heureux à noël là dans une
semaine que ces gens ne l'ont été en
recevant sa ce jour là aux plages les
rafales et suis l'un passe à autre chose
l'emballage ça compte aussi bon c'est
quoi vos techniques pour jean remballer
nickel vos cadeaux il j'ai fait une
dinguerie j'avais plus de papier cadeau
c'était le jour de noël c'était genre en
une heure avant noël littéralement avant
que j'aille chez ma mère pour fêter noël
et je sais que ce jour là j'ai fait un
move qu'uniquement l'élite de l'élite
qui est en train de regarder cette vidéo
a fait j'ai pris des feuilles a4 c'est
tout ce que j'avais chez moi et j'en ai
scotché plein autour du carton et je
vais vous faire ça je vous cache pas que
c'était pas un gros moment j'avais un
peu honte s'abattre offert à ma mère aux
noms mec c'est ignoble a cédé truc ultra
solide pour attacher des trucs ensemble
mais c'est l'enfer mais que c'est un
cadeau en soi l'emballage cadeau qu'il a
fait c'est un casse-tête en vrai cet
emballage cadeau si tu me fuis de lapin
ce qui va avec pour couper chaque truc
c'est plutôt cool tu m'offres un truc
très satisfaisant à faire je suis plutôt
content en fait en plus sacrés de la
tante avant que j'atteigne le cadeau
qu'ils sont intérieur c'est ce que je
suis complètement à côté de la plaque
mon frère ne déçoit jamais avec ses
cadeaux de noël personnalisés cette
année il m'a fait un calendrier vous
voyez les cadeaux personnalisés
franchement les gars j'en ai jamais fait
et c'est la première année où je vais en
faire la passe comment jeter dans cette
vidéo j'ai du temps vous la voyez neuf
jours après bon entre temps j'ai fait
tous les petits cadeaux perso j brassage
peut pas sauver votre noël non plus bon
le 30 janvier le jour des croissants le
14 février saint valentin au nom ça tue
mais c'est un an de travail au
calendrier qu'il a fait là il est
complètement chômage ton frère je suis
désolé en plus il fait des montages
regarder on dirait mes vidéos anecdotes
ça tue attention le prochain cadeau est
un gag préparez-vous à rire et 3 2 1
unitems de switch
en fait je trouve ce n'est que mon avis
le vôtre est moins bien mais à
l'ouverture il ya un truc un peu drôle
de genre à jeu de mots nintendo switcher
en fait c'est juste un switch sur un
interrupteur qui m'a offert et après
c'est fini le cadeau est terminée il
s'arrête là ce cadeau dure dix secondes
ça vous allez le garder je défends
tellement les mugs là ont dirigé des
parts dans une entreprise qui fait des
modes personnalisés pour le moment bon
mais peut-être qu'après cette vidéo tout
le monde post c'est incroyable santa
secret' voici le pire je crois descente
à secret's et quand tu fais un noël avec
tes amis en fait est que tu tire au sort
et que chacun doit acheter un cadeau à
la personne dont il a tiré au sort le
nom c'est assez marrant à faire fait
l'antre vous alors qu'est-ce qu'il a
reçues l'uaw à frire ou l'emballage
c'est une dinguerie déjà fait chaud ils
ont emballé ça dans un plaid quoi les
salopards tu as arrêté les appeler les
flics
mais dès ramène à cuisson instantanée
deux préservatifs des trombones
mec attendriez d'explication et je pense
que l'explication doit être à la hauteur
du foutage de gueule désolé frérot
j'avais oublié et c'est tout ce que j'ai
trouvé dans ma boîte à gants sicre et de
santé
on sait même pas c'est quoi le jeu vidéo
mon gars il a une cartouche de vidéos
dans sa boîte à gants elle est plus
vieille que la voiture c'est incroyable
assal donne envie de faire un petit
santa secret' là encore faut-il des amis
[Musique]
pour mon secret de santa j'ai reçu une
poubelle
moi franchement je suis pour les trucs
utiles en vrai tu aurais pu avoir pire
quoi j'essaie de te rassure nos frères
rochus hypocrite j'ai dit à ma grand
mère que j'étais dans le gaming voilà ce
qu'elle m'a offert à noël
ça c'est dur elle était sur un style
s'est pris une pub aliexpress tu sors
des fois quand tu te prends un cadeau tu
sens que à l'origine de ce cadeau il ya
une pub très bien ciblé sur la personne
qui te l'a offert genre mon père un jour
il a offert quoi il avait fait un truc
custom des serviettes de bain avec nos
noms marqué dessus et c'est manger soit
une pub soit un article sponsorisé sur
un média qu'il a l'habitude de suivre
genre le cas d'omar en affaires à son
enfant qui a entre 18 et 22 ans le truc
bien ciblé apparemment ils ont voulu
faire genre qui lui offrit un horrible
cadeaux et ça a mal tourné ou bien
tourner je sais pas il lui offre quoi
une banane frérot
oh non il est quand même contente
offrez-lui le monde
et nous on va aller on va aller alors
vous recevez des jeux vidéo servez tout
baghlan question mon mari reçoit tout le
temps des crayons de couleur pour son
anniversaire ou noël sauf qu'ils
détestent ça parce qu'il est daltonien
mais ils sont horribles ton entourage
excusez moi mais c'est quand même un
croit il a toujours voulu un iphone donc
aujourd'hui j'en ai acheté un mais je
les cacher dans une boîte de crayons de
couleur ouah ça c'est ça semeta ça
j'aime bien voyez le cadre le pam état
mais la manière de lukla là c'est beau
gosse quoi et c'est exactement parce
qu'il ya des gens qui ont des idées
comme ça que des gens comme nous panique
à chaque noël fait chier là j'ai acheté
un collier à ma femme pour noël beau
gosse le mec m'a demandé si je le
voulais emballé vous souhaitez vous
un paquet cadeau j'ai dit oui et je lui
ai demandé de faire l'emballage le plus
horrible possible pas beau gosse la
frérot tu as réussi à faire pire que mon
truc de feuilles a4 franchement pour ça
tu gagnes un switch bravo honnêtement si
vous divorcez quelle part avec la
plupart des meubles et la garde des
enfants tu ne peux pas te plaindre
honnêtement ma femme à bruges offre un
cadeau qui vaut moins de 2 euros perso
tu me demande ça je t'offre deux avocats
et pas mûres bat nantes
7 quel troll j'adore les cadeaux pour y
mêler cadeau pourri mais t'as quoi quel
boss est excellent j'ai demandé à ma
femme de m'acheter la nes min pour noël
j'aurais dû être plus clair
what the fuck frigo mais qu en fait mais
d'abord ils ont sorti la mini n'est ce
donc ils y apprennent un peu plus loin
deux jeux intégrés et cetera qu'un
hommage à la vraie n'est ce donc
consoles rétro qui a marqué l'histoire
du jeu vidéo sauf que la belle inès tu
peux jouer c'est une vraie console là
c'est une annonay ce qu'elle a trouvé ce
qui veut dire qu'il ya des gens quand
nintendo a annoncé la mine il est jugé
au lancer un business de faire des micro
micro naissent pour jouer sur
l'ambiguïté et que des gens se fassent
avoir et achète la neige c'est
incroyable égalé businessman vous ne
cesserai jamais de m'étonner bande de
chiens olala je suis désolé pour toi
j'espère au moins que tu es offert cette
banane avec parce qu'on a vu que les
bananes ça peut régaler à noël attend
des nouveaux postes de cette même
personne blague à part désormais avec
mon fils on essaie d'avoir toutes les
miniatures de consoles qui existent
voici notre collection
ohwawa alors l'âge identifié un problème
incroyable le frérot il a trop de fierté
il est en train de faire genre qui la
quiche et la baisse miniature pour faire
genre auprès de sa femme que sa blague à
la troba marché a acquis les encore plus
content que s'ils avaient eu la mine
inez laisse toi aller laisse toi gay
c'est pas grave s'il n'y a rien de
honteux
c'est un peu comme quand même je crois
leur fille a reçu un bang pour noël les
parents meurent à l'intérieur
ça c'est une incroyable j'ai jamais
pensé à faire sa course off des trucs
genre hyper révélateur de trucs dark
avec mon frère devant nos parents c'est
génial tous ceux qui ont des frères et
soeurs là devant la vidéo fait ça
ma grand mère adore nous acheter des
puzzles à noël elle pensait que c'était
le puzzle d'un elfe il est dix fois
mieux que c'est un il est incroyable
dont puzzle mille fois mieux que c'était
un elfe bien jouer grand mère moi je
pense qu'elle joua l'idiote parce que ça
amuse la famille mais que c'est calculé
ça attention sous-estimé pas les
grands-mères un petit souvenir de
l'année dernière quand j'ai offert à ma
grand mère un portrait de jésus
c'est obi wan il est fier elle lui en
veut il ya de la prod derrière ça fait
de la muscu des bottes une zone où il
neige il habite au canada dans le nord
raccord avec ce mur type chalets type
d'habitation qu'on trouve dans les zones
enneigées mais je reconnais cette montre
c'est du mauvais goût oh encore
un cadeau d'une grand-mère les gars je
commence à être méfiants là les cadeaux
des grands parents ça a l'air compliqué
de plus en plus
oh mec
mais c'est mignon elle a dû crois que
c'était un truc un peu d'animer
références pop culture est ou non ça
veut dire que ton petit fils aime
regarder juste sous forme d'animations
et ça veut dire que tu as envie que tout
le monde le sache ma vie mais je dames
c'est la fin de cette vidéo j'espère que
ma mission est accomplie que vous avez
été inspiré ou rassurer sur vos cadeaux
des années passées en vrai de vrai cette
tradition des cadeaux c'est toujours
trop marrant j'ai un truc de curiosité
bizarre à chaque fois j'aime trop
découvrir qui a offert quoi et qu'y
courage h f comme on dit à tous et à
toutes pour vos cadeaux moins vrai ça
m'a aidé et je crois j'ai eu quelques
idées de trucs rigolos là que je veux
offrir je pense que ça va être là un
festival de cadeaux personnalisés pour
moi cette année bref passez tous un
joyeux noël dure à une vidéo avant noël
je crois le 22 mai j'ai déjà tourné donc
on se parle pas avant après noël c'est
pour ça que je dis ça profitez-en bien
amusez vous bien manger bien surtout
pour moi noël c'est de la bouffe c'est
des calories avant tout et profitez de
vos proches parce qu'un jour ils
mourront
d où tout le monde s'était acheté un
cadeau faux
tu m'aimes tu es aux
deux formations
[Musique]